congratulations Mickey you have one big
brother
[Applause]
big winner of the night has it hit you
yet have you processed that you are the
winner of Big Brother 21 and clearly my
reaction on stage shows that it hasn't
there's a lot of mixed emotions and the
slime from day one on my move-in shirt
shows that it hasn't hit me but you know
it's it's what I came here to do I had a
job to do and I saw it through to the
end and I walked out with the confetti
always wanted what was going through
your head cuz it was hard to read your
face when you walked out those doors
what were you thinking well you know I
know in this experience that you are
putting yourself under a microscope for
the entire country to dissect you pick
you apart from every angle good bad ugly
in between and I got hit with some hard
questions some questions that are very
against every grain in my body
racism disrespect towards women things
that I do not tolerate or stand for and
it's a lot of interpretations a lot of
bitter opinions and everyone has a right
to him and I've also said things that I
do regret said things that I'm not proud
of said things in heat of the moment
that this house will bring out of you
but getting hit with those in that chair
trying to get half a million next to the
girl that I love more than anything in
this house that I've worked so hard to
be there for see my parents on the front
row confetti hits it was a rollercoaster
but as it started to sink in it's
relieving it's relieving to be done and
it's relieving to have the outcome that
always worked let's talk about the happy
stuff you and Holly yes where are we
taking this thing where's it going Holly
and I first were going to Disney World
and then we're going to Bora Bora and we
have a deal we shook on it that
regardless of whether we were in a
relationship or not every year we have
to take at least one trip and it has to
be the exact opposite of the location
that the year before was so if we go
tropical this year we got to go
somewhere cold next year but we are
taking it one day at a time just like in
this game we're both very mature
rational people with that and we're not
going to pressure anything whatever
happens happens and if her life in my
life are able to coincide
synergistically and do our thing
together than great but regardless she
will always be in my life she's a great
girl and will be one of my best friends
outside of this thing and I love her to
death and whether we were in a
relationship or not will not change her
place more right now tonight she's your
girlfriend
oh yeah we're together great
yes yes there's not a question about
that at six months six days six weeks
six years I don't have a crystal ball
but I'm looking forward to her when
she's done with all these two because as
soon as you get out of this backyard you
just go to the party get some drinks
have a real night together yes and my
parents I need to see my parents you
miss my folks I need to see them and
hers this is like a rapid-fire
relationship you moved in together first
yeah and then she's gonna immediately
meet the family
and the thing is is that my family knows
her her family knows to me but I've
never met them and she's never met mine
so they have their opinions of us and
there's nothing we can really do to fix
it except give it time and see what
happens so it's interesting let's talk
about that tough moment you were
confronted with some stuff that you
don't you know you don't know about yeah
really how are you gonna process that
are you gonna go home and watch it and
figure out what happened I made my bed I
got a lady and I will go full force in
it I'm not gonna sugarcoat first thing
I'm doing is watching this full season I
want to know exactly what has happened
and the way it's being portrayed I've
said things in the heat of the moment
that I know I can be aggressive with I
know it can be abrasive I get very works
out I'm an intense person I do
everything full-speed and that is the
good and the bad when someone upsets me
they upset me regardless of race
religion age sexual orientation whatever
it might be gender and I know that about
myself and I know need to work on it but
at no point am I ever
you know targeting someone or speaking
badly about someone because of any of
those factors it's because something
that they have said is upsetting me or
you know Kat for example her and I
bicker like siblings but there's also
been numerous conversations that we've
had where we make up when we love each
other we argue just like in real life
people argue but the difference is
people see in your own record you're on
camera you're on audio and there's no
escaping that so I will own everything I
said and there are some things that I
wish I could challenge but at the end of
the day the reasons why I said them were
never malicious they were never about
race religion gender sexual orientation
any of that nature it was because one
person to another person I was upset
okay I'm gonna tell you to stay off
Twitter for a moment at least let let
people watch the episode let a few days
pass because there are people have
labeled you a liar a cheater
so there's gonna be some stuff to
process everyone's singing but has one
my fellow houseguests have one you have
one America has one I know that I'd
busted my ass in this game I came in to
play Big Brother and there was nothing I
wouldn't do to win big brother anything
in life worth doing is worth overdoing
moderation is for cowards if I'm going
to do this thing I will play it adapted
to my environment I conform to whatever
I needed to to succeed and I fought day
in and day out and a lot of my strategy
at the beginning of this thing was to
paint targets on other people bigger
than myself and boost egos the loud
personalities fuel them build them up so
that way I would not be the first picked
off happened on day 44 and I was finally
able to play my own big brother from day
44 on I was finally myself first half I
wasn't allowed myself to compete
I wasn't being much yourself my
personality I was being what the people
in my Alliance were and I was doing
whatever necessary to fuel the large
targets my alliance after that and I was
on my own I had nothing to lose I'm
gonna play my own game and that's where
you saw that transition happened it's
because I went from having to put on an
act to be something I'm not to survive
with the numbers to then being able to
fight and scrap the way that I want to
so you overall happy with your game feel
like you played a clean game in there
the end of the day I have made mistakes
in life and some of the biggest mistakes
I've made still led me to this point and
I will learn from them I will grow from
them and this is no different I have no
idea of what people can grow or have
been saying about me but what I do know
is who I am and I know what I stand for
and I know that I accomplished the goal
that I came from for whatever happens
after this I will again take it on the
chin I made my bed I got Elena at the
party today I'm gonna recommend go
apologize to Tommy Tommy yeah he told
that big line I did I had to it was him
or Holly and I'm never gonna turn my
back on her and she's never turned her
back on me there's nothing I wouldn't do
for her inside of this house or outside
of it I'm loyal to a fault to those that
are also loyal to me and my actions have
shown that
there's nothing I wouldn't do for the
people that would be there for me before
I let you go I got in get your reaction
to Nick and Kat hooking up in the jury
house Oh buddy you know I would have put
money on it if I was a bettin man that
it would maybe be Jack and Kat because
Jack was there first you know whatever
but Jack really did likes us a lot I I
love Nick I love Kat I have no idea what
has happened in the jury house just I
have no idea what has happened outside
of this house in the real world but that
was interesting I didn't expect it but
that's reality TV for you there's
content so I have one more reveal for
you do you know what the viewer is
called Holly all season long gorgeous
Beth Oh Beth from David's impersonation
of Beth that is how if you go on Twitter
in search of Beth they're talking about
Holly Wow David left his mark on Holly
Beth from Montana and she's Holly from
Wyoming yep that's funny that's funny
that's funny
so I'll let you go celebrate your win
but would you go back and do it all
again are you one and done I would do it
again I would do it again it's it's
something that I enjoyed it's something
I've always wanted to do
would I do it differently I have no idea
you have a plan walking into this house
and when you open that door and you see
your houseguests it all gets flipped on
its axis you know if I could do this
experience again same people never known
each other it might be a different
outcome but it was an experience always
what I do and I did it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]